hey guys it's alex welcome to my
apartment i'm about to make one of my
all-time favorite recipes for mac and
cheese now obviously mac and cheese is
one of the ultimate comfort foods so at
a time like this it really comes in
handy listen i know some ingredients are
a little hard to come by right now but
this recipe is super simple uses a lot
of ingredients you might already have in
your pantry and if you can't get
everything at least i hope it inspires
you to make a creation of your own
alright let's get cheesy
i'm already pretty cheesy but
all right welcome to my kitchen so for
this mac and cheese recipe we're going
to be using a few basic ingredients
pasta of course
you can use whatever kind of pasta you
have on hand i'm using orecchiette for
the next key ingredient the cheese of
course we're going to be using two
different types sharp cheddar and
gruyere you can use pre-shredded cheese
you can also use whatever kind of cheese
you like again we're not being picky
here for the other dairy we're going to
be using milk and heavy cream if you
don't have heavy cream you can use an
extra cup of milk for the topping i'm
going to be using panko breadcrumbs you
can use regular breadcrumbs you could
also get creative crush up some crackers
crush up some chips it's the perfect
time to be creative and for our
remaining ingredients pantry staples
butter oil salt pepper flour
that's it let's get cooking
[Music]
all right so i got my water boiling i am
going to salt this pretty generously i
like my pasta water to be really salty
because your pasta will absorb that salt
and be flavored they say it should be
as salty as the sea
now i'm going to add in my pasta again
i'm using oiketi
i'm just going to do the full box
stir that up a little
so i'm going to be cooking my pasta to
just before al dente we're not cooking
it all the way through because we're
going to be baking the mac and cheese
later and we don't want our pasta to be
mushy so i'm going to let my pasta cook
for about seven to eight minutes but
then we'll be ready to move on all right
our pasta is done it's al dente i gave
it a little taste
i'm gonna drain this and then we'll move
on
all right my pasta is drained i'm
putting it back in our pot
right in there
so i'm just gonna be setting it aside on
the counter for later you don't need to
put in the fridge or anything crazy just
let it hang out pasta is done
now it's time to get cheesy so like i
said i'm gonna be using two types of
cheese sharp cheddar and gruyere we need
a lot of it so let's get going we need
about four cups of this cheddar cheese
and two cups of the gruyere
i've been eating a lot of mac and cheese
i have to say it's like one of my go-to
comfort foods and right now
we all need a little extra comfort am i
right
wow look at this big bowl of cheese
it's as big as my head back to the stove
we go
it's just over here
so to start we're gonna make our roux
the roux is the butter and the flour
mixture this will help thicken things up
so first i'm gonna melt six tablespoons
of butter
i am using a pretty deep pretty big
saucepan here because
we got a lot of cheese this recipe is
definitely not healthy but you know
who's keeping track these days
all right my butter is melted down i'm
going to add in the flour i'm gonna be
whisking this pretty constantly to make
sure the flour does not clump
and just keep it moving
so it's not exactly ideal to use this
metal whisk on my non-stick pan but it's
all i got right now don't come for me
internet
be gentle with me i'm fragile
right now
i've been alone so long
so i'm just gonna start gradually
pouring this in
whisking while i go and again take your
time here
we just want to make sure that
the sauce is as smooth and creamy as it
can possibly be
and then a heavy cream
and now i'm just going to continue to
keep this up for a few minutes stirring
to make sure we get a nice
silky smooth sauce our sauce is looking
really beautiful it's thickening up
really nicely i'm gonna season this with
some salt
[Music]
and some pepper
you can do this to taste
i turn the heat down now to like a
medium low just to make sure
it doesn't get too hot
we don't want our sauce burning
it's beautiful
time for the cheese we're going to do it
in batches to make sure it melts down
each time
[Music]
guys this is looking so good already
i can't wait i mean if you're gonna eat
mac and cheese you might as well
go for it right
all right the last of our cheese going
in
the final
stir
listen
she's nice and thick
beautiful i kind of want to eat it is
that bad can i try it i guess there's no
rules who am i asking i'm here alone
oh my god
come on
i can eat that straight out of the bowl
we don't even have to go on
we're done goodbye guys see you next
time just kidding
all right it is time to add our pasta
i'm just gonna dump that right in there
into our cheesy deliciousness
oh
now we just want to coat all of our
pasta in our delicious
cheese sauce
listen to that it's like asmr
[Music]
all right our mac and cheese is looking
beautiful honestly you could stop and
eat this right now but i've got some
extra time on my hands so we're just
gonna take it up to the next level
all right moving on to our final bonus
step we're gonna make our topping this
is great for adding a little extra
crunch a little extra texture typically
i'd use regular pinko but i only have
whole wheat panko right now totally fine
and i get like that little extra health
kick
so i have two cups of panko i'm gonna
add six tablespoons of melted butter
and a cup of shredded parmesan cheese
mix that up
[Music]
all right topping is done that was super
easy
time to assemble
we're at the home stretch i'm getting
really excited also very hungry so i'm
ready for this so i'm just gonna pour
this right into a greased baking dish
you need a pretty big dish for this
if you don't have a big enough dish you
could also just separate it into two
do two smaller ones and now
for the final element our topping
skin it all over the top
oh this looks so good
can't wait to try it
all right so my oven is preheated to 350
degrees i'm going to bake this for about
30 minutes and then
we can dig in
all right let's take a look
oh man
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
wow
this is gonna last me like a year
now if you haven't you can garnish this
with some fresh chopped parsley some
green onion something green
i don't have that so i'm not gonna do it
[Music]
looks so good
nice and hot nice and cheesy a little
crunchy i can't wait to try it
oh my god i'm gonna need a minute alone
good thing i have a loaded microphone
there's definitely ain't no box mac and
cheese let me tell ya
well that is my ultimate mac and cheese
i had a blast making it i'm gonna have a
blast eating it i hope it inspires you
to do some good cooking of your own if
you want me to try out anything else let
me know and i'll see you guys later
[Music]
you